eh bien écoutez bonjour à toutes et à
tous ici regret que j'espère que vous
allez bien
alors il est temps c'est évident
j'allais faire cette vidéo alors je sors
de la douche et je suis dans la salle de
bain parce que je n'ai pas d'autre
endroit pour faire cette vidéo mais le
trailer de star wars 8 vient d'être
vient de sortir tout simplement
et du coup nous allons le regarder
ensemble et l'analyser alors par contre
évidemment ça va être une réaction à
chaud ça va pas être une alice trou en
profondeur sachant qu'en plus ce n'est
même pas encore sous titrée en français
donc nous allons perdre pas mal d'infos
mais on va essayer d'en décortiquer un
maximum je lance la vidéo dans trois
deux un top
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis
[Musique]
kershaw
le cas
[Musique]
m
tox
rens
[Musique]
sans compter que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais non moins de chance
car j'en ai les mains moites faut que je
retire ce truc-là set 4-2 et day au
[ __ ] il ya tellement de choses alors
déjà je pense que donc on va analyser
vite fait alors je pense avoir raison
quand il dit respire respire je me sens
bien que ces de l'udc
arrête de la voix c'est lui qui par
l'arrêt et de plus quand il dit respire
tout ça en fait il lui apprend à
maîtriser la force et remettre
simplement donc on a vu plein de choses
[ __ ] c'est tellement chaude tout
mémoriser je crois que je vais règles
regarder en même temps à ce que du coup
il lui fait ouais il lui apprend il va
le luxe va apprendre la force arrêt
c'est sûr de plus
donc du coup nous voyons les îles à d
l'eia pardon à qui est toujours là ça
c'est tout à fait normal alors ready
qu'elle voit la lumière
en même temps elle voit lorsque
l'obscurité elle voit l' équilibre donc
déjà je trouve ça intéressant à ce que
ça veut dire que revêt ne voit pas que
le côté lumineux reste entre deux alors
soit les considérer comme une élue qui
est ni du côté jedi ni du côté obscur et
qui va amener une sorte d' équilibre
ou bien le terme de deux bons côtés
n'existe plus en fait de côté obscur et
de côté lumineux en fait on a l'exemple
avec mass kanata qui maîtrise la force
mais qui ne s'en sert pas
coup dur pour le bien ou pour le mal en
fait tout simplement
enfin c'est assez compliqué alors qu'est
ce qu'il y avait d'autres aussi bien
j'étais surtout sous le choc
donc elle voit l'équilibré lors du coup
c'est est sous-titré alors ça au final
je pensais que ce n'était pas ce titre
et donc ça je pense que c'est je pense
vraiment que c'était la voix de l'udc en
anglais du coup alors on voit des aussi
d'élever saut un moment donc ces
vaisseaux je pense que c'est ceux du
premier ordre
les couleurs utilisées pour savoir the
last jedi nous informer bien que le
premier ordre va vraiment faire chier
les rebelles les rebelles vont être en
assez mauvaise posture
il me semble donc on voit fine aussi
fine a évidemment fine et en guérison de
de sa blessure contre kei lorraine et on
va pas le voir du film je ne pense pas
du tout qu'on va le voir du film ou
alors à la fin et je pense pas qu'on va
le voir énormément
il ya toujours peau d'iron avec bébé 8
ça fait plaisir
et voilà il ya la base le trailer nous
montre bien la base des rebelles explose
d'autres vaisseaux des rebelles explose
c'est
c'est la merde c'est la merde les
rebelles vont en chier leur race c'est
sûr à 100%
et là le meilleur passage c'est quand
ray cours avec son sabre c'est
exactement ce que je pensais que j'étais
sûr rêve à apprendre la force avec luc
et ensuite elle va devenir une jedi et
là du coup c'est le cas elle devient une
jedi et là comme ses films est en fait
un vrai cours avec son sabre et justes
en voix de kelly lorraine
alors ces deux plans différents parce
que je pense pas que c'est un combat
entre
auray et kelly lorraine mais il va y
avoir soi c'est comment expliquer ça
soit ces menteurs soit c'est trompeur
soit va y avoir vraiment un combat entre
ray et cahill lorraine et la salle r d
de plans différents mais un rêve à
combattre quelle reine si je comprends
ce que veut me faire passer le trailer
et services connaît vraiment épique
est-ce que calais lorraine a vraiment
une tête là à être encore beaucoup plus
méchant et ça fait plaisir
donc là il ya toujours pareil donc ça
alors attendre il ya un moment il ya un
moment aussi j'ai du mal à comprendre je
sais pas si c'était parce que là avec r2
d2 avec r2 d2 c'était qu'il y avait une
personne acquiert de d2 c'était je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas du tout qui sait
n'étaient pas ceux bizarrement que je
sais pas
ce serait les gaous luc normalement donc
là une grande guerre comme je le pensais
pareil et il est temps pour les jets
d'ailleurs ça c'est la phrase il est
temps pour les jedi d'en finir chance
que madame en trois théories sur la fin
de star wars est assez clair j'ai dit
qu'il y avait d'autres jedi peut-être
peut-être qu'il y aura d'autres jedi
caché dans l'univers et il est temps
pour les jedi d'en finir
donc lorsque ça ça suppose c'est que ce
serait la fin des jedi parce qu'il est
temps pour les jedi d'en finir c'est que
après ce sera fini normalement le jedi
n'aura plus de jedi enfin d'après ce que
je comprends après la guerre quoi donc
l'udc n'est pas tout seul arrêt non plus
et voilà relief ne sont pas tout seuls
en tant que jedi c'est vraiment ce que
je pense d'après le trailer c'est ce que
je comprends j'essaye des conseillers de
comprendre un maximum et d'exprimer un
maximum d'informations parce que c'est
assez compliqué mais
je pense vraiment que ça va être ça le
13 décembre cinéma un classique et c'est
franchement c'est cool et je suis
vraiment trop trop pressé je sais pas ce
que vous en pensez mais moi je suis
vraiment hype et de bouffe le trailer il
envoyer du lourd
il était courant mai l'envoyé du lot et
ça fait vraiment plaisir il a envoyé en
tout cas bas je vous fais des gros
bisous je remercie d'avoir regardé c'est
une vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et à devenir un liner du coup en tout
cas bas la file phrase que je vous dis à
chaque fois 7 et arago rock que le liner
soit avec vous
[Musique]